im netz häufen sich die
weltuntergangsszenarien zum 23 september
2017 die prophezeiung reichen von einem
planeten einschlag auf der erde bis hin
zur ausführlichen sie sich uns an diesem
tag offenbaren werden all diese theorie
stützen sich auf eine besondere
sternenkonstellation an diesem tag was
dran ist und was auf jeden fall an brian
fallon 2017 passieren wird denn es wird
etwas passieren
erfahrt ihr jetzt bei pixum zwischen
herzlich willkommen
ehrlich gesagt ich kann es gar nicht
mehr zählen wie oft der erde
der weltuntergang bisher gedroht hat
eigentlich gibt es kaum ein jahr in dem
es nicht ein bestimmtes datum von
gewissen leuten mit spannung erwartet
wird bei verschiedenen
katastrophenszenarien vorausgesagt
werden im jahr 2000 weg sehen ist dies
der 23 september also bleibt uns mal
wieder nicht mehr wirklich viel zeit
unser leben so wie wir es bisher kennen
zu genießen eine besondere
sternenkonstellation an diesem tag soll
die basis für die verschiedenen vor
heerwagen liefern den vorschlag für
dieses videos den hat übrigens philipp
geliefert an dieser stelle herzlichen
dank also wie sie die sterne
konfiguration an diesem tag aus und was
ist das besondere und verzeiht mir die
blumige ausschmückung aber das sieht
einfach ungemein die verschiedenen
weltuntergangsszenarien wie ich euch
gleich vorstellen werde
von einem sternbild abzuleiten die sonne
soll astronomisch gesehen im haupt des
sternbildes jungen frau stehen der mond
zeitgleich zu ihren füßen das sternbild
löwe besteht aus neun sternen und
sondern diesem tag zudem noch durch die
drei planeten merkur venus und mars
ergänzt werden insgesamt also zwölf
himmelskörper die sich ausgerechnet am
23 september zum 17
am kopf der jungfrau ihrer krone quasi
befinden sollen einige gehen davon aus
dass zu dem jupiter auf einer linie
quasi zwischen den beinen der jungfrau
entlang wandern soll und damit jetzt
direkt zur ersten vorhersage die das
ganze spektakel als eine art planeten
geburtstag
das muss man den
verschwörungstheoretikern lassen sie
geben einfach nicht klein bei und
erwarten ja zum wirklich xten mal dass
ein unbekannter planet nahm niveau oder
planet xviii denen oft auch nennen die
erde zerstören wie man natürlich ganz
sicher am 23 september 2017 diese
theorie beschreibt beispielsweise der
britische autor und
verschwörungstheoretiker david mit
ausführlichen büro soll demnach am
südpol einschlagen und wohl den großteil
aller menschen vernichten
einige der verschwörungstheorie wir
gehen davon aus dass die öffentlichkeit
über dieses ereignis bewusst im unklaren
gelassen wird damit sich nur die elite
darauf vorbereiten kann das thema hatten
wir schon mal
denn ähnliche vorhersagen weder für 2009
noch für 2012 noch für 2015 oder 2016
eingetreten inhaltlich stützen sich die
anhänger dieser theorie ihrer
überzeugung nach auf die nasa die den
mit der löwen planeten die beruf vor
längerer zeit einmal mit dem ihrer
satelliten beobachtet haben soll wer des
untergangs fanatiker sind nämlich davon
überzeugt dass die nasa niveau 1983
entdeckt hat aber seit dem tod schweiz
um eine massenpanik auf der erde zu
vermeiden jeder wissenschaftliche
beitrag indem irgendwie der begriff
planet iks vorkommt wird von ihnen als
bestätigung für ihre katastrophen
szenarien angesehen was war wirklich
dahintersteckt den begriff plane takes
den gibt's ja im wissenschaftsrat welche
hier steht aber für einen hypothetischen
planeten in der äußeren regionen des
sonnensystems und na klar auch die nasa
sucht nach unbekannten planeten im
äußeren sonnensystem doch mit dem welt
verschwörerischen büro dessen existenz
nicht mal bewiesen ist hat das nur macht
überhaupt nichts zu tun die nasa hatte
ja tatsächlich zu dem planeten geäußert
und entwarnung gegeben ihr könnt euch
also entspannen aller wahrscheinlichkeit
nach hätten astronomen solche einen
hobby astronomen durch einen planeten
der auf dem weg in richtung erde wäre
schon seit einiger zeit auf dem schirm
er müsste inzwischen jedem von jedem
entdeckt worden seien und er wäre
mittlerweile sogar mit dem bloßen auge
erkennbar also abhaken büro werden wir
nicht zu gesicht bekommen geschweige
denn wird er die welt zerstören aber
auch einige passionierte liebe leser
erwarten den 23 september 2017 mit
spannung die konstellation der sterne an
diesem tag soll nämlich einen bestimmten
verkauf der liebe nämlich 51 aus der
offenbarung johannes beschreiben und ein
großes teilchen wurde am himmel gesehen
eine frau umhüllt mit der sonne und der
mond war unter ihren füßen und eine
krone von zwölf sterne war auf ihrem auf
und sie war schwanger und sie schreibt
in ihrem wehen und geburtsschmerzen für
einige jetzt muss schon sagen fanatische
bibel anhänger dieser bibeltext exakte
beschreibung des sternbildes an diesem
tag die sonne steht im haupt des
sternbildes jungfrau der mond zeitgleich
zu ihren füßen das sternbild lösen
den sternen unserer sieben tag zudem
noch von drei planeten merkur venus mars
inhalten insgesamt also zwölf
himmelskörper die ausgerechnet am 23
september 2017 wie sich am kopf der
jungen frau ihrer krone quasi befinden
sollen
das hatten wir ja schon mal und das
übrigens alles über der stadt jerusalem
das verleitet aber fanatische bibel
anhänger direkt zu mehreren möglichen
szenarien für den tag ihr nur ein paar
von ihnen heraus gepickt der große kampf
zwischen satan jesus wird stattfinden
der kampf zwischen gut und böse die
dieser kommt von jesus ist nahe
die zeit des trips satz beginnt es
werden bemerkenswerte veränderung
stattfinden und und und wenn er mich
fragt ist das wie so oft in der religion
alles natürlich frei interpretierbar und
glaube da wird natürlich auch nicht auf
fakten
dennoch stimmen die details des
vorhergesagten sternbild nicht wirklich
mit dem bibeltext überein den planeten
sind nun mal keine sterne
aber das wusste man was man sicher noch
nicht und außerdem ist in vers 12 1 von
einer frau oder noch besser weit die
rede und nicht von an der jungfrau also
abgehakt und damit also weiter zur
nächsten theorie die außerirdischen die
habt ja bitte sagen sicher schon
vermisst so sind einige ufo
verschwörungstheoretiker überzeugt davon
dass uns am tanzen september 2010
endlich außerirdische über ihre existenz
informieren ob dies mehr oder weniger
liebevoll tun darüber sind sich die ufo
verschwörungstheoretiker setzt aber noch
nicht einig und falls euch jetzt das
vorausgesagte sternbild vom anfang
september 2017 irgendwie auffüllt gebe
ich euch noch die folgenden fact mit auf
den weg venus jupiter natur sonne mond
und mars befinden sich an diesem tag
wahrscheinlich genau auf einer linie von
der erde aus gesehen
die formulierung auf einer linie lässt
allerdings immer etwas in der
fraktionsführung offen und natürlich
stehen alle wandel sterne immer etwa
ringsherum einer gedachten linie es gibt
zeiten da gleich die konzentration er
einer linie als eben zu anderen
zeitpunkten mit der tatsächlichen
konstellation im raum hat das rein gar
nichts zu tun und man wird es auch
leider nicht sehen können da die sonne
viel zu hell ist können wir also auch
abhaken hat mich und ver durch aber zum
schluss kann ich euch noch verraten
das kann sicher an diesem mysteriösen
tag passieren verpasst durch diesen
ganzen dieses ganze turbo nicht den
astronomischen herbstanfang am anfang
september die sonne wird an diesem tag
zwölf stunden über dem horizont stehen
und den äquator in südlicher richtung
überqueren so dass von nun an die tage
wieder kürzer als die nächte werden wenn
ihr keine videos mehr zu den nächsten
anstehenden weltuntergänge kaputten
wollten wir hier ein abo aufs auge und
vergällt nicht den genau auf die glocke
hier geht es weiter mit
wird ein planet unsere erde zerstören da
geht es noch mal sehr detailliert um
libero wenn euch dieses weltuntergangs
szenario noch mehr interessiert dann um
den kauf klicken und ansonsten bis dann
bleibt dran